right nice the videos will be coming out
soon
for those your time to be gonna relive
your best moments for those of you
didn't attend you get to relive their
best moments they in the photography
will put a bunch of photos taken by our
speaker today you took photos of the
conference he has a fancy new camera he
likes to use so speaking of the pizza
everyone should go to bit dot ly / Pizza
pole and rank the pizza from excellent
to good average more and ever again go
on their rate the pizza today comes from
hiline pizza up on 28th Street I've
actually never even eaten there before
today so this is completely untested so
please make sure you go to bit ly /
Pizza Pole it's very important to
collect this data thanks to Thomas
Levine's amazing painting he made he's
working arm hang about the pizza Bay
meetings oh that's great fantastic
there's a line JSON feet of the data
which I assume Thomas be pulling from
hopefully not hand in coding so
everyone's going to go to fit li / pizza
pole next up 80 jobs is anyone hiring
alright I see a lot of hands you can do
it in order well first a word from our
hosts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
please do fences stand or that damn
another job again
music now
hey guys I'm Patrick that via
transportation or will they get a work
I'm sorry yes and also please of your
ability and check out the musicality
hey guys stream products and you'll took
around my music to anyone else over here
I think that Mike should be hot I can't
promise not that I'm sure we can get it
turned out please I'm gonna say keep
singing again again this repetition is
important check and hang out by the
music when you're done
I'm working there's just like Silicon
Valley great overview guys fight no we
want to see anyone notes alright that
was jobs afterwards we always go to a
bar and we're in a new neighborhood
there's not neighbor we've come to
recently for a meet-up so we have
decided that we are going to go to the
standard herb garden who knows where
that is raise your hands who knows where
that ism is gonna come you're gonna be
the Pied Pipers in no one I presume it's
on goop you will be one of the Pied
Pipers leading people to the bar I will
lead people JT you believe people it's
on Google Maps right okay so afterwards
we'll go to the standard beer garden
it's underneath the High Line attached
to the standard hotel is the most biri
biri place in the neighbor there those
cocktail bars so we need to find a way
to give this away
we will draw around a number then
somebody's number the seats are no
weekend well you do it by row and by
seat and then you figure it out
section row seat okay that's what we'll
do so we have three things to give away
the smaller prizes first I'm gonna gonna
live code our sample oh I was just gonna
do like roses you like the first thing
will say section two those are one
second do it though one two three one
two three so section two is here so you
to Road three one two three to the crowd
you to fight over oh that should be your
presenter presenter gift this is
beautiful of the iris dataset and it's
just the basic color sepals the length
on the y-axis and the width on the
x-axis
and there's some flower pot in case you
haven't used it before it's a scatter
plot put it on if there are multiple
points on the same point then it makes a
flower instead of just a point
[Music]
good I do the troll go bit the other
time we did it like I
you're doing great where you look like
this is good look like like I was being
giving it yes so here's what we'll do
actually I feel guilty because I just
talked my way into he give us at free
and I'm southern and we just can't do
that so I'll be doing an auction and
we're gonna I think women who code is
gonna be who receives this so we'll do
it online I'll figure out exactly how to
do that this may take us a few weeks to
get lined up with that we're gonna raise
some money for charity this is beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
next month's it's already scheduled was
not scheduled though the page will go up
tomorrow
it is Rob in d'avin who does our Rob in
Venice all right let me ask you maybe
you might have used this package it's
the forecast package who has used the
forecast package it's about doing time
series analysis he's coming from
Australia to New York City next month
also the meeteth on enough for you he's
also putting on a two-day workshop so if
you want to actually learn for two full
days and brought him in sign up for the
workshop though see the details in the
good in the meet up goes up I'm very
excited masking for two years to come to
New York City we finally got him here
I'm very excited to have them and then
last question I've been asking around a
lot of people do people liked it did you
get the title of the talk
and if you doing Jenna I know if you
everybody under 40 is like what the [ __ ]
and everybody over for days like oh yeah
tell me that they are actually there are
little because they didn't understand
the words in the talk for beginners so I
want that everyone understands that this
is an awesome pun and that we have an
awesome speaker it's been coming to the
meetup coil he's overcome a few years
but he's been known to the meetup
because it was great twittering at scene
mastication for about a decade so I want
everyone to give a very warm welcome to
JD all right thank you guys
fantastic I have tremendous lights in my
eyes and not a very good reflective
anti-reflective coating on my glasses so
see you guys let's see I'll cover where
the title that talk came from this is
gonna be a beginners talk I was talking
to somebody earlier but you know I kind
of heard of the flyer and I feel like I
should be using it but I don't really
know what it is like you're our target
audience if you're here and you've got
years of experience who's got you know
more than a year experience using be
flyer right okay so everybody who came
here to hear me like these the people
gonna be asking questions too if I can't
answer so the reason that I chose chose
this topic is I just learned it myself I
started the Chicago our user group eight
nine years ago I'm not sure how long it
was I've not been a big user of deep
liar there's some drawbacks to some of
the tiny versus packages and I'm going
to cover that if a bit at the end and
we're going to talk about some tension
that we may have picked up on at the our
conference between the tidy verse and
the not let's call it the tidy verse and
the chicago school right so there's this
there's this you know and I'm an
economist so I'm used to the Chicago
School having a bit of a beef with
everybody else so this is really
comfortable territory for me so we'll
talk about that in a minute so and some
of you are like not gonna care about the
inside baseball but it's actually a
little bit interesting about why there
are different groups of our users doing
some different things and it's worth
thinking about because there's some
really legitimate points on both sides
and
in my only technical skill is empathy so
hopefully I can empathize with where
each group is coming from and can maybe
help you guys understand that a bit so
we got we got lots of people here from
all over where's where's my West Point
crew ant I lost them some of their there
so I really hope that much that my
presentation is good because I do not
want to end up in the floor bird at
their Humvee with a brown bag over my
head again so um all right where are we
going I actually spoke more for this
slide than I usually do I'm a big fan of
like lead with where it is we're going
my wife was a newspaper reporter in her
first life she said business people
always bury the lead like we never tell
anybody where we're going and we walk
them through like how we got there at
the end they have no idea why that this
was where we were ultimately going so
I'm gonna start with where we're going
all right deep liar can be fast to write
it can write SQL for you deep liar
writing SQL is fast typically faster
than you can write SQL or at least
faster than I am I'm gonna have one
controversial idea one warning and one
hack all right so we'll stack those up
to be but this is gonna kind of be step
by step deep liar chunks how to do
something all of the code is available
for this presentation it's on my github
account so you can download the this is
just an HTML page it's got all the
pictures embedded in the HTML so you
don't have to get the HTML plus a bunch
of other crap the HTML page has it all
there's also the source code that
generated this you can run it on your
machine it's all in our markdown so JD
who I'm Jamie long also first name is
James middle name is David that's the JD
and I've been on Twitter for a while
about six years ago I moved from Chicago
to Bermuda and the first few weeks I was
in Bermuda
Bermuda's population of 50,000 people
Brighton whole country it's a little
bitty island 20 square miles out in the
middle of the Atlantic Ocean
I used to tell everybody they'd ask
where do you live and I'm like oh I'm
about you know 600 miles east of Ahoskie
North Carolina and they'd go and they'd
later figure out I just said 600 these
ha skeet or Carolina so I lived out in
the middle the ocean and the local
newspaper ran a article about the
Bermudian z-- with the most Twitter
followers I had not changed my location
to Bermuda I had it changed like summers
Islands or something which is the old
name the old British name for Bermuda
I had it something kind of obfuscated I
would have been like number 6 in the
country
I just stopped using Twitter right I'm
like I'm kind of new to this position at
this company and I don't want to be the
guy who's like Twitter famous over some
piece of obscure technology that no one
in the country has ever heard of oh yeah
so when I moved back to the states we
just kind of open the spigot on Twitter
again and so I've been fairly active in
the last couple years since I've been
back here I'm also been and past really
active on Stack Overflow I was involved
in the group that helped bootstrap
getting the our tag on Stack Overflow
initially and we did that by seeding
Stack Overflow with a bunch of popular
questions and answers like beginner
thanks to in order to drive initial
traffic to Stack Overflow no formal
affiliation with Stack Overflow I was
just really pissed off at how grumpy our
help was and wanted to like redirect
people over to this friendlier
environment a little bit I know that
apparently Stack Overflow was going to
become sort of less friendly over time
but at the time it was a really good
place and it's still incredibly useful
and even this week when preparing for
this presentation I asked a stupid
question on Stack Overflow so and got
embarrassed so OPP summer of 1991 27
years ago the group Naughty by Nature
had the smash hit OPP and we were
looking for a term to capture packages
and our that sort of follow the tidy
verse standard the tidy way of doing
things maybe use some tidy packages in
those packages but they weren't they
didn't get maybe I should define what
the tiny vs. right so if you if you if
you type library tidy verse
into your our session you're gonna get I
got only the number off top of my head
but it's this many packages get loaded
and then if you say I'm sorry if you say
install packages tighteners you get this
many if you say library tidy verse to
load that you get this many right so it
installs a bunch but when you call it it
give you this many so well in the in the
vernacular this these packages are like
court ID verse and these are in the tidy
verse because they get installed when
you install packages tidy verse all
right well there's these other packages
right this other stuff what do we call
them and I've been helping polity to
work on the our cookbook to kind of
bring it up it's it was written eight
years ago I was a technical reviewer on
it for a Riley and so we're having to
explain some of these concepts so I'm
trying to be really precise with my
language and I have suggested that we
call you know these like court ID verse
then there's like recommended maybe or
not core and then there's these others
and these others I'm convinced should be
called tiny by nature and it's a play on
naughty by nature right because I'm so
I'm a big fan of our puns our puns rock
has anybody ever seen this syntax and
rsync something to Devon all it just
throws it away right it takes the output
and sends it to Devon all I thought this
was so funny that I named my boat
Devon own so this is the Unsinkable
Devon oh and I'm sure the guy who bought
this from me when I when I left to burn
boot I was like so alright now I usually
don't talk about where I work I usually
say James long Meg Nana's cocktail party
toast or something like that and in my
BIOS I actually worked for eNOS on Surry
we're a global reinsurance company based
in Bermuda with offices and big offices
in New York Bermuda
Londyn small office in Singapore big
office in Dublin and we have a
meteorological group on the East Coast
we are actually hiring and so I'm
usually don't associate because our top
stock trades down every time I'm
associated with the company but we are
hiring a risk analyst here in the New
York area early to mid career it's not
an R centric job but you do get to work
with me it's not reporting to me it's
reporting to one of my peers
she actually sits right behind me so but
you do get to team with me and so Billy
comm RN R underscore job takes you to my
github page where there's a link to the
PDF job description we do you work
through recruiters so you can't like
google and find this but if you are
interested come talk to me pull the job
description up there all right let's
talk about deep flier so with the lights
you can't really leave the back there so
I'm gonna have to spend part of my time
and file over my back to the guys from
West Point we're gonna set up an example
first I'm just gonna load tidy verse
we're not gonna load just deep liar or
have other stuff we're just gonna load
packages willy-nilly so I'm gonna load
the tidy verse and then we're going to
take this empty cars data set that comes
with R and I'm gonna use a function
called row name two columns because we
have this data has row names and stupid
I want them actually in a column so I
create a column named long name and now
we got this thing called DF underscore
cars it's just the cars data in a data
frame is anybody in here and please
don't hesitate to like give me the high
sign because I need to know a little bit
where to start with some of this is
anybody not familiar with that percent
dollar a percent greater than percent
symbol okay I've got a couple three look
that's a pipe and what a pipe does if
you had any experience from command-line
especially in UNIX will take one command
and then will pipe the output of that
command into another command and what
this does in R is it takes the first
thing or
the result of the first thing in this
case empty cars is just data it takes
that and it pushes it as the first
argument of the next thing and in wine
so here the row names two column there's
an implied empty cars goes here comma
var name long name so I could have
written that out long wise by putting
empty cars is the first argument there
and what about this right assignment
arrow who in here uses write assignments
who in here is made slightly
uncomfortable by my use of the right
side yeah all right I know my audience
oh yeah this is my controversial idea
because this will this'll divide a crowd
man the idea is in our you can make that
little sign Manero point either
direction as a matter of fact you can
take an object put an arrow on either
side and it will sign that middle object
to both of those through the one on
either side man r does not give a [ __ ]
it's the honey badger of assignment
operators right it's like I don't care
left right right - laughs man Jewish
Arab we don't care man let's just do
this so I am assigning and I love this
syntax because we go from the left
through the next item through the right
and dump it into an object this is just
like how we would do in the UNIX command
line where we do scat something push it
into a function push it into something
else and then shoot it into a file it's
conceptually the same thing so I'm going
to use that over and over and we'll
revisit it later
so the deep layer select statement is
like select in SQL we're going to say
take the DF car data shove it into a
select and just keep these three columns
now these three columns are this long
name that I've recreated while ago that
I created while ago cylinder and hhp
number so under source powers car's data
and then I pipe that into head now I
also do something here with head I don't
have any parentheses within heads a
function gives us the top six rows but I
don't even have any parentheses there if
you're only past
the thing from the pipe in that into
your function you can put the
parentheses there you cannot put the
parentheses there hard does not give a
[ __ ] and I don't either all right so
let's do a filter all right so the first
line their long name cylinder horsepower
now the other thing to notice here and
this makes my friends who come from the
Python world uncomfortable yes sir oh
man you're gonna have all kinds of mess
I don't know and neither do you so don't
do that
[Laughter]
something magical I'm sure DF cars here
we're gonna select long name cylinder
horsepower and you know for most other
programming languages when you start
talking about fields in another object
you got to do like that other object dot
the field or that other object
you know dollar sign the field name well
it's implied when you're using D plier
and this is part of what makes it fast
to type and so a huge part of analysis
is shortening the distance between your
head and the end of your fingers and so
if we have to type fewer you know DF
cars over and over and over in front of
every field name you can dump your ideas
faster into code so the idea is no
quotes around it no qualifying the names
just shove them in there and all of
these functions are gonna kind of work
like that so here I've added filter and
a filter does what it says on the tin
it's going to filter by certain criteria
so this is number of solar cylinders
double equals so the comparison operator
number cylinders equal to eight and then
spit that to head and so now you see it
pulled you know records where the number
of cylinders is equal to eight so each
of these things I'm introducing you to
as a verb you can think of D plier as a
grammar of data analysis kind of like
ggplot is a grammar of graphics this is
sort of D players at a grammar of data
analysis here we've introduced a new
verb so we got a verb select we have
filter and we've introduced a verb
mutate what mutates going to do is
create and you call them so I'm gonna do
a couple of them here I'm going to do
the first one
I don't know this isn't meaningful right
I'm just making dummy data to illustrate
this and I wanted short names and short
functions so I did the square root of
worse power and call that square root
underscore horsepower and another one
called short name that uses a function
called word to grab the first word of
the long name so usually that's the the
mate right so it's making model and so
that grabs just the make so you can see
if you look at the column short name
here
you know it's caught the first word of
this
alright let's introduce another verb
group by group by short name so you may
be used to group bys in SQL and in SQL
whenever you do a group by it actually
like results in data that's been reduced
down to the unique number of groups one
thing that may be a gotcha when you come
to deep liar or for that matter pandas
in Python is when you do a group buy it
doesn't actually change your data so if
you look down below like that same data
we've been pushing around before you can
see the the three records there that are
all Mercedes there's three mercs there
right but yet I grouped by a short name
so you might if you come from SQL and
expect that to have done something it
actually doesn't change the data what it
does change is you look up at the top it
tells you this is a table which is just
a tiny data frame and it says it has
groups it says this group to a short
name so that's just an indicator for
future functions that whatever we
summarized on later will be by groups
but right now it's not my group it's not
its grouped but it's not reduced in the
number of groups all right so I'm gonna
I'm gonna do some cleanup here cuz my
examples getting too long for me to just
add verbs every time so we're gonna do a
couple things and also my data was
getting too wide it wasn't fit I'm gonna
do a select with a negative so you see
where I negated long name that means
drop it
so it'll take whatever was there select
long name so
their horsepower had a column name short
name dropped long name so I'm left with
short named cylinder horsepower and as
you see when I do a head on that data
that's what we have all right we're
gonna take just a little tangent why do
this PI there's a handful of people who
hadn't seen the pipe what's the sales
pitch for why they should go home and
investigate the pipe because I don't
know what the hell is going on in this
character but it does exactly the same
thing that pipe sequence did I showed
you a couple slides ago and the reason
it's hard for me to read is it's
completely dependent on us interpreting
the white space to figure out which loop
we're not loop where and which function
we're in to understand which argument is
applying to with it what bit and this
ain't Python we shouldn't be carrying
about white space to understand where we
are so you can see actually and it ends
up looking like lisp with all these
hanging these closing parentheses at the
end you know the one of the complaints
about Lisp is it looks like somebody
turned their fingernails on your code
because you've got this hanging out
little closed parenthesis but this code
runs and it does the same thing but what
I did is I just nested all the commands
inside of each other most people you
don't don't actually write it like this
but God knows I've written much code
looks like this so this is actually
really common this is what most of us do
right we'll do a select we shove it in
this thing like okay it's only got three
variables I'll call it DF car three
bears and then oh I might add to call it
maybe short name well we're gonna do
cars three bears short name and then I'm
gonna do something to that and then at
some point the second the third choice I
over wrote my original data frame but
the top one I didn't so we leave this
trail of periodic data frames behind us
in our analysis like [ __ ] falling off a
truck and you just you end up with a
bunch of copies and it can cause a real
reproducibility problem when you go back
to try to rerun parts because if you
change the data frames out of order
you can have real problems of your
analysis so this is so much cleaner to
read and I think that kind of undeniably
so and you may not want to use pipes and
everything you may not want to use
timers that's fine you don't have to but
this is amazingly clean to me to
understand what's happening now I'm a
little constrained because all these
examples I'm trying to fit in a stupid
little code box right and I'm also
trying to make sure the records don't
fall off the screen that way so I've
tried to pick very concise examples but
in real life you're gonna be a little
wider but it's still really easy to
track what's going on my code is way
more readable with deep liar all right
summarize I promised we would do
something and it would actually take
that grouping business into account so
here we're going to group by short name
and number of cylinders and we're gonna
average the horsepower take the mean
horsepower all right so have you
introduced this verb summarize and
summarize I'm going to need to give it a
function that can operate on a vector of
data because it's going to get a chunk
it's going to get whatever is in each
group and so you can think of what ours
or V flyer is doing behind the scenes is
just like in SQL group wise it's gonna
effectively take your data frame
conceptually break it into a bunch of
little data frames and like here I'm
doing some operation on horsepower so
that's gonna take the vector that
represents the horsepower column and
it's gonna shove that for you just that
group into the mean function right
conceptually really straightforward and
that's what it does I just print out the
top three now but something you may
notice and this was a real gotcha to me
and I didn't know what was going on I
ran into this where it were it changed
when I was seeing or made a function not
work like I was expecting you see I
grouped by two things up there right I
grouped by short name and so under but
it if you look at that result of that it
only is grouped by one name it's only
grouped by short name
anybody here know why that is
there's the answer ding-ding-ding
meaning summarize we'll every single
time drop your last group by variable
that is in the documentation it's how
it's designed and from looking at the
github history for deep liar about once
a month somebody says what the [ __ ]
and I'd know this because I went there
to say what the [ __ ]
and so I actually recommended proposed a
change that deep liar present a message
that says hey we're dropping and Hadley
told me like look now because this is
the expected behavior grouping when you
group with left with a grouping that is
only one row which is what it has to be
after you've run one group by having a
grouping that's only one row big Mason
is not useful it is never useful and so
it doesn't conceptually make sense so we
just dropped the last one I'm with you
and I've actually the funny thing is
I've actually used this as a feature
because you could do a group by and then
you do another summarize and you've got
one less grouping automatically so if
you know you're going to do that
workflow you don't have to do that
second group by you're already you just
put the variable you want to drop as
your last group by element it falls off
after you do the summarize and you're
right where you want to be so in some
ways you can end up writing less code
just it can surprise you like it did me
well we can joins just like SQL and we
you know do joins and base are in this
case I'm creating some dummy like a
dummy mapping table off to the side
where I map the numbers four six eight
into the words four six eight and then I
join them to the DF cars limited and you
notice I don't tell it what field to
join by right well deep wire will look
and say okay you've got us someone
you've got a field called cyl this data
frame that you're joining to has a field
called cyl and it will send a message
saying joining by sea well it would just
kind of find all of the if you have
multiple
names that are joined by all of them if
that's not what you want you can
override that and tell it what to group
what to join by or to join on but that's
pretty neat once again can be very
concise when you're typing this out all
right we can do a case when this is a
another verb in our deflower verb we're
almost through with verbs I'm going to
illustrate a few more of these and then
just show you the list of the rest of
them you can send you home to read up by
yourself but this one I found incredibly
useful so I create a variable here I'm a
mutase so I'm adding a new calculated
field called POW and POW is when the
horsepower is over 200 and the syllables
are over cylinders are alight we call it
strong and then I just do this thing
where I say true weak
well what I'm doing here is the way case
win works is you give it conditions so
that's one condition horsepower over 200
and cylinder greater than equal named
both of those have to be true and then
see the twiddle so this is like formula
notation so we say when the stuff on the
left side of the twiddle is true we do
the thing on the right side well the
thing on the left side of the twiddle in
my second line my weak is just true it's
always evaluates to true so this is case
when right this I mean this is if then
else
it's your else right so I just you know
as soon as it hits one that's true it
will do that and then if it doesn't meet
any other criteria it'll do the other
the very last line there all right I've
been using mutate versus summarize
pretty straightforward if you've used
them but let me just reiterate mutate
adds columns but keeps the same number
of rows summarized adds the column but
reduces the rows down to one per unique
group based on whatever you were grouped
by so should be pretty straightforward
but they're kind of similar concepts
they both can be used to add columns all
right that's great and that's all been
on local database
data frames let's do database so this is
what brought me to deep wire and why I
decided to learn it about six months ago
let's make a connection in this case I'm
going to just do a connection to a local
SQL database an SQLite database just
running on my local machine and I could
have used this this convenience command
called min DB frame and it would do the
same thing but I want to show actually
making a connection because if you were
connecting to redshift Postgres whatever
your favorite database is you would do
it like this you would create some sort
of dbi connection string probably call
it Conn and then you would use that
connection so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna actually copy I'm gonna copy some
data so my copy to is a deep layer
command that's gonna copy data to the
connection it's gonna copy the DF cars
data frame that's this one we've been
playing with it's gonna put it in a
table called DF cars and I'm gonna set
temporary equal false so it'll still be
there for multiple commands and I'm
gonna do this connection so that's
connecting to the database now I'm gonna
make a connection to the table I'm gonna
make this DF cars underscore DB is gonna
be a tipple that I can act on just like
the other tables which are tiny data
frames I can act on it the same way but
underneath it's actually my database so
I do the TBL command tell it the
connection told the name of the table
and now I'm connected so if I look at
what class each of these things already
been throwing around so DF cars is
really straightforward it's a data frame
the if I wrap it in as Tibble so it's a
local data frame DF cars I wrap it in as
Tibble and say what's the class it's
this table DF TBL data frame we call it
so it's still just a table and the third
one if I take the DF cars DB it's a
table now it's a table that's got this
SQL and DB I thing in it and that's how
I know it is a
- oh like backed by remote data yes
ma'am
[Music]
correct and I'll and I'll reiterate that
just to make sure about she asked did I
connect to another database an outside
database I said yes
in this example it's local to the
machine but this could be my redshift
database on Amazon my copy to command
here is let's set up dummy data like in
your in my real life I already have crap
over a database right and then the third
step with this DF cars DB I think of
this like a logical link in your file
system it's a pointer to something over
on the database but I didn't move any
data back yet it's just like a place
keeper saying this data is gonna come
from there it's like a promise that I'm
gonna use that data behind this thing
but not yet and we're gonna execute on
that the takeaway here is really if you
see this TBL under store SQL when you do
the class if you get confused you're
debugging that tells you it's backed by
this like remote promise or I'm not sure
what the right way to describe this that
will resonate all right so this looks
sane right there's gonna look a lot like
what we did while ago I think I changed
a little bit but we're gonna take this
DF cars DB which is now living over on
our database and I'm gonna pipe it
through a group by then I'm gonna pipe
it to the summarize and take the average
and standard deviation and call that
thing mean horsepower by cylinder and
then take the head it just runs but this
didn't run on my machine well it did
because this beta baby didn't run it ran
because of an SQL query behind it
created on the fly by R by B plier all
right so this is that same query but the
last step instead of shoving it into
this object called mean horsepower by
cylinder I just shove it into a function
called show query and it dumps out the
SQL that would need to be in order to
get that
so this thing is dynamically writing SQL
behind the scenes right all right
it's kind of smart about how it does it
so if I had this workflow where I do a
group by then I do a summarize and then
I do a filter well my filter is after
the summarize and then I show the query
you can see it's smart enough to
effectively I change the form just to
let you guys know if you do this at home
it's not gonna output so I can look
exactly like that it's gonna kind of
dump it in a run-on sentence and I
formatted the SQL so you guys could tell
what the heck's going on but this is the
SQL you get out the other side I just
added formatting but you can see it puts
it does the selection and the group by
and then it wraps that in another you
know select star and then do the do the
where condition down at the bottom so
it's kind of smart about the SQL it
writes and I mean I heard mention while
ago someone's using redshift we use
redshift and what I found is these
queries that are nested like this or
super well they play very well with a
query optimizer and redshift and so the
SQL that I write might write I might try
to use some temporary tables or try to
do CTE s or something in my SQL I found
this sort of nested SQL the query
optimizer can traverse it and understand
what's going on the query optimizer over
on redshift and my queries become more
performant than that which I might write
by hand only because these are fine when
you just got a couple of nests if you
have like once you get like seven deep
and you got a bunch of fields these can
get god-awful to keep track of so oh yes
it's magic
now I mentioned lazy I think I used the
term lazy and you may have even seen the
lazy mentioned the table was a late lazy
query what does this mean the lazy means
it doesn't deep lie or doesn't go get
the data until it needs the data and you
either explicitly ask it we're gonna use
a command called collect to tell it go
get what's in this table that's backed
by SQL and then it'll actually
materialize it on your local machine or
if you call a function like earlier I
called the head function and it needed
some of the data in order to present
ahead it'll do that in order but if you
do the head it won't just get what it
needs and won't get your whole thing so
this can be really useful so here I pull
in and I understand from of it this kind
of when I'm debugging stuff or using
this I have gotten where I take to
putting local in front of stuff I have
returned from the database so I can keep
track of what's a pointer to something
over on my database and what has
actually been materialized back to my
session of our so by using this collect
command
it tells deep liar go fetch the day that
shove it in that data frame so there's a
whole bunch of our that's been mapped to
SQL but it's pretty short list compared
to all the things you can do it alright
so this is basic data manipulation verbs
what it doesn't have is all of our
statistic functions
you know our building regressions and
all that that's not you know easily
conducive all to SQL I've seen the SQL
that does a correlation matrix in SQL
and it made me want to punch the guy
that root it because it's just the wrong
tool for the job right so what we need
to think about doing is this is a tool
that allows us to take a chunk of our
data out bring it a manageable chunk
either because it's an aggregate it's a
grouped in some way it's a sample
because you can do sample
with this and sample from your database
take a random sample or a subset bring
them into our and do something
interesting you know in memory on a
local machine so this is one of the
design patterns for big data in 20th
century is a whole bunch time you don't
need all your data you just need some
aggregation of it locally to do
something meaningful and this bridges
that gap especially if you're your big
SQL thing on the back end is like spark
or Amazon redshift sorry need more
there's a vignette for the SQL
translation for deep liar I haven't used
the term DB plyer in here behind the
scenes there's a package called DB prior
and it's all the backends for deep liar
the backends to connect to the databases
so you may see that mentioned all right
well I want to talk about a few kind of
advanced not advanced a to a few out of
mainstream situations one is you need to
produce a reproducible example in order
to ask somebody on Stack Overflow or
somewhere else for help well you can't
give them access to your database right
let's be usually you can't so how do you
ask for help right because the first
thing if you don't they're gonna say
well that's really interesting problem I
wish I could help you but you don't have
reproducible example so go [ __ ] yourself
and they kind of got a point yeah they
kind of can't help you
well Headley sort of saw this coming and
then the other people who did DB Flyer
so I'm actually gonna load DB plier here
and we're gonna use you see me making a
data frame here I've got this x and y
all I'm doing here is telling it I could
have put one for both of them I'm
telling it that x and y are both
integers right I just need some
placeholder data we're never going to
use the actual data here we're using
this to create dummy SQL and this is
useful also for debugging yourself and
I'm gonna use this two commands together
TBL underscore lazy and the source
equals simulate SQLite so what that does
I pipe my data into that common
two functions and it creates this lazy
table called DF underscore sql-like what
that is is enough of a trick to tell
deep liar this is an SQLite database
it's just a placeholder and if you dump
commands against it like I do here is
summarized and then you do show query it
will show you the SQL that it would
write if you were using an SQLite
database and you take this exact same
command sequence change the back end to
like simulate Postgres and it will show
you the SQL that it would write if you
had a Postgres on the back end this is
how you create dummy examples for
understanding for yourself what it will
do but more importantly so someone else
if you're reporting a bug or if you're
asking someone else for help you can
actually illustrate what it is you're
seeing you can say I do this and I see
this I expected to see something
different why am i seeing what I'm
seeing
right so it allows you to make a
reproducible example incredibly helpful
we can simulate a bunch of stuff you
know Postgres ODBC connections SQL I
have my sequel Impala Oracle these are
also all the stuff that we have backends
for in DB plier all right a couple of
snags at least for me that I've ran into
one is like when I connect to redshift
I have different things in my search
path automatically so like we have a
directory sorry a database schema called
public one called reports one called
sandbox and one for me as a user
I've got to explicitly state that you'll
just get the one default I have no idea
what other databases do all of my in
anger usage has been against redshift I
bet it's the same way with Postgres
because red shift has Postgres as the
interface
it's like Postgres with a different
datastore on the backend so I'm
suspicious other post graphs act the
same way just know that that's a thing
like if you can't find your your table
it may be because it's not
default search path name clashes on join
so if I join what we do is we have for
convenience a certain field maybe in
multiple tables if I join all those up
and it's not a field I'm joining on it
just was put in a couple of different
places because of how we use the data
it's duplicate data we didn't fully
normalize our data on purpose if it gets
that field you know Bob and Bob is
available in two tables and they all get
joined to to dim tables and they all get
joined overcome in fact you can't have
like a resulting thing with two tables
called Bob so what it's going to do
automatically and invisibly is the first
one is going to become Bob dot X and the
second one is going to become Bob dot y
that can be a real surprise like because
you won't have any Bob table you've been
used to having Bob Bob's gone man
what you can do is if you notice on my
connection when I do the TBL Connect DF
cars I also threw in a select - sorry
about the poorly placed line break there
it was not like that before I swear I
dropped in this example I might have two
weights so I just drop one of them from
one of the tables right and that
prevents me from having a naming clash
and then I get in this case a WT field
or in my other example I get one Bob
field Bob Bob all right my workflow with
redshift ID right when I was doing this
this afternoon I did a I did a count and
so we have 350 roughly billion rows in
our redshift database that I'm pounding
on every day right
most of my query is complete in about a
minute right so it's pretty reasonable
database what I do is I predefined all
my joins so all that TBL business and
then I do all my join so maybe I join
like 10 dim tables to one fact table I
do all that in a function or in
something that I source so that's kind
of done behind the scenes my scripts
don't have that junk in there I just
start with like one big table
everything in my whole freakin database
kind of logically joined up into one
table and then I set up a bunch of queer
conditions a bunch of group buys do some
transforms some of those are in
functions because I do them over and
over again and I do all my transforms
and then all at the end of it I collect
it right and I'm maybe only getting back
100 rows or ten rows something
significantly smaller this is a pretty
good workflow for what I do I don't know
if it'll work for what you do but it's a
way to think about workflows all right
let's talk about what happened at the
our user conference here in New York
when Jeff Ryan spoke about the plier and
he said should never never never never
never never never break an API all right
and I think a bunch people didn't
realize like what Jeff's talking about
what Jeff's talking about is deep liar
stomps all over existing API and it
fundamentally changes our when you load
it I'm gonna time series data I do a lag
on it 12 unit lag so an annual lag and I
get some data right and you I can set k
equal to 12 or just pass it to 12
because K is the number of units to lag
and it produces the same data either way
this is how our work and has worked
that's how s works right this lag
function goes back pre are all right now
if I load D plier and run that exact
same command changing none of my code I
get an error and it doesn't matter if I
say equals 12 or K not equal 12 this
error is caused because L deaths is a
time series object and the D plier lag
function then work on time series
objects well you know you get at least a
meaningful error it's like you sure you
didn't mean stats long all right so go
in here and put stats log
I'm sorry stats lag not long lag in here
and all right we're back to getting what
we want we fully qualified it as stats
well you have to change all your code if
you've got an existing code base and you
want to bring deep lier into it you're
using lag you got to test and change
code all right here's the problem though
if if you had instead of L deaths being
time series I converted it to a double
that's the only thing I changed so now
it's a vector of doubles and then I run
it through okay that works with the old
lag this gets gives us the same thing
but with deep liar we get nothing but
Nance if you aren't printing that vector
out or have something that doesn't like
Nan's down the road you could just be
getting wrong answers and if you're in a
high frequency trading shop you could
lose a crapload of money before you
figure out that you broke your code and
that's problematic right so this points
to if you're using you know your code
and anger beyond you know desktop
analysis to actually make money when you
start adding new packages whether it's
deep flyers or other make sure you got
regression test you know make sure you
got something where you say does this
thing change the answer in some way so
you know I was fortunate enough to be
hanging out at the bar with Jeff and
David Robinson and this is pretty much
the conversation as I heard it so you
know a lot of the argument is that the
tidy verse and deep liar are the best
tools for learning are and I think David
Robinson has a great point I think
they're very very tractable and it's a
great workflow and I'm using right I'm
using them in anger at my office Jeff's
like yes the best way to produce hidden
errors in your code base Jeff works in
hedge fund and their code needs to have
a different degree of stability than
other people's code I don't know where
your code sets I know where my code sets
and I'm gonna take this to heart right
there's there's good points here on both
sides and so this is the gist of why
there is some tidy verse pushback from
parts of the our community as parts they
are communities
like whoa man you are upsetting the
applecart entirely too much too fast and
your stuff will just break our code
that's worked since s like before the
our language existed what we used worked
and now you're breaking it and that
doesn't feel right and you know those
other groups that say all right we're
really writing we've got this long
future of future users and if we change
some things now for the future users
there's more future users of our than
there are current users right so how do
you discount a time flow of future users
well these two people discount it
differently right and that's okay but
you got to know how you discount it when
you're figuring out what works in in
your flow so alright the other
controversy I mentioned was this write
assignment I use this I just want you to
know that Hadley welcome is recorded on
the record as saying this is really
appealing really easy to read and don't
ever do it I'm doing it because it's
beautiful in my opinion it doesn't break
anything always works the the one thing
notice there's no left indent on my
result I really think you need to always
do that because if you have it up after
the arrow on the right it gets hidden it
maybe get cut off if your text editor
isn't wide enough and you can't figure
out where some assignment happened you
lose it make that thing always left
justified now the problem is if you take
this code block copy and paste it our
studio will conveniently write bump that
funfun data here it'll bump that over
cuz it's like oh no that doesn't go all
the way over there
so if I can get enough people using it
will do will ask it our studio to change
that out all right last thing before I
wrap up is some some people myself
included have functions that aren't
vectorized I glossed over the mutate
just mutate adds a column if your
function that you want to add your
column with is not vectorized you can't
just like mutate at it right because r
doesn't know what to do you'll actually
end result with everything in that
column being exactly the same value I'm
not gonna explain this um this is all in
github and we'll search
a link this is how you do row-wise
iteration using well first I just set up
the data and a function and then I set
up a row rise operation where we use P
map from per and list to pass named
objects this is really useful I feel
like I've taken entirely too much of
your time so I'm not gonna get into the
details of it but go for it just know
that you can also shove vectors in the
cells in data frames people forget they
can do this this may or may not be a
good idea that usually people discover
this by accident because they didn't
intend to return a vector and they're
horrified because Excel usually doesn't
let you do that right that's our analogy
when we come to our know that you can do
that and there's times it's the right
thing to do it allows you to keep this
tidy workflow where every row is an
observation because if you've got a
uncertain number of things you need to
shove into a cell this gif does it it
leaves you with a tidy data frame so
it's got some appeal using carefully no
you're doing it and on that I'm just
gonna ask for some questions so I'm kind
of dumped a lot at you guys let's see
we're gonna both mics on and Jared's got
a mic the deep the vignette that I
pointed to the SQL translation vignette
the one of the cat I think it's when you
got the picture yeah so I'm sorry I that
you won't get the actual meeting motion
unless you took a video you do the video
that's where you get cracked not every
function is not there
yeah yeah first of all we should stay
they're incompatible right you're not
going to shove data tables through these
deep liar functions because data tables
have a like a completely different
syntax for operating with them they
aren't like data frames data tables are
super cool
they're very performant they're really
fast usually I am of the opinion people
ask me if they should be using data
tables and I'm like do you have a
performance problem right because you've
got to learn a new API a new syntax to
interact with them and that can be
really useful but you've also gotta
forego some other tools so most of my
life I'm constrained like by the
distance between my head and my fingers
like getting the idea captured in code
is the hard part the runtime is actually
you know with the exception of some of
my long queries usually not my biggest
constraint I use so I use data tables
hardly at all like I used them some
years ago to try to understand what they
were the people I know who used them
have workflows where you've got big
tables doing lots of transforms and
maybe even like lots of looping and I
haven't benchmarked their code but I'm
suspicious they need it for those
reasons right so it's a trade-off
Oh deep liar will be slower in terms of
in terms of execution speed now what's
interesting is at some point there's a
okay I'm an economist right so I'm gonna
start using eking economists words
there's a fixed cost marginal cost piece
to having your data on a remote database
so you know I just showed you we have
300 something billion rows when I send
off a query there's a every query takes
like at least as long as it takes the
processor to dump that query over the
wire go to Amazon get executed marshal
the data back into an object and slurp
it back over I think of that as most
butts there's some chunk on that's a
fixed cost right it doesn't matter how
big the table is something that's got to
happen and then there's a marginal
component about how much data am i
bringing back so if what do you do a lot
of is some operation that doesn't bring
a lot of data back or can leave it in an
SQL database until you only have to
bring a little bit of data over I
benchmark that against using something
like redshift with deep liar I can't
just like blindly give you guideposts
because I don't really know it totally
depends on your workflow
actually I may ask you to stay there cuz
I'm only vaguely familiar with the
problem the snag becomes when you don't
fully qualify the function name is that
what or what is the I saw somebody no
the workaround for this yeah what's your
work round cuz I don't I don't use these
in packaged stuff and honestly I don't
have a package on cream that was the I
had seen that and I couldn't pull it out
of my memory bank yeah it's it's dot
dollar and then it knows they're fully
qualified yeah so yeah so if you're
gonna use these in packages that are
going on cran you got to throw a little
bit more at it I was just gonna mention
I glossed by it because I didn't delve
into a Jinni Brian from our studio has a
I have a bitly link there bit Leandro
why's she has a document full of
examples of row-by-row
workflows with deep liar and or / if
that is appealing to you I recommend
like taking a picture of that link
there's actually a really really simple
answer for that one works faster in New
Zealand and the other works faster in
the United States it's completely
because well do you guys know why
Tibbles are called Tibbles because
that's the way a Kiwi pronounces table
right so the New Zealand accent someone
says table it comes out like Tibble if
you're from New Zealand so that's the
some work that's that's with I call it
the metric Spelling's right it's the
that's that's what those are it's
completely the same function underneath
you create a data frame and then put
that explain the workflow where that
happens is you're trying to be tidy and
by tidy every row is an observation
every column is some variable and one of
your variables has multiple stuff like
multiple observations for some multiple
aspects of one variable for that
observation you got two choices you can
either replicate your row so your that
row maybe each row represents a person
in a study you could replicate that row
and each row being one time they were
measured for the Ted whatever test it
was that sort of breaks this tidy
paradigm where you have one row per
Purab support per participant in your
study so you may choose at that point to
when you bring that data in lunge it
around in such a way that you're
basically putting comma separated values
effectively inside of individual cells
conceptually right it's a vector it
shows up when you print it out as comma
separated or if the result of for
example I could shove the result of the
linear regression in a Cell in a data
frame that might not be a bad workflow
in certain cases where you're doing a
different linear regression for every
piece of data in your data frame you
might want to show the whole result it's
one of those things that should be done
judiciously because you do break
something when you do that right it
makes it a little hard to have a
meaningful CSV that you can dump out
into other stuff
yeah yeah you can shove it straight into
the data frame right or you can put them
as individual records into a master data
frame and then join that to just think
about it there's one of those things you
you know it's kind of like I'm Mark
Twain said he got wind broke you know
really slowly and then really fast
well you'll kind of find that when
you'll not use this at all and then
you'll use it like four or five times
because it'll be the right solution for
the workflow you have and I can't
imagine what workflows you will have in
the future where it's meaningful
don't make that happen like but if it
makes sense yeah yeah the example where
I did it I use the I use the the map
function usually well the reason that
happens is the sequence function returns
a vector it produces a sequence from A
to B by C and so if you look down here
in the bottom what I did mid max range
ABC so we go from one day by one so
that's eight numbers we go from 2 to 13
by 2 that's that 2 to 12 and then we go
3 to 18 by 3 and that's that 3 to 18
it's because that function returns a
vector this workflow will just shove it
into a cell pop that whole vector in
there the example before it what
happened I had that right there I had
the function that sequence wrapped in a
sum I just added those numbers up
because I wanted I wanted single atomic
values for my illustration and there I
just left that some off so I would get a
vector but that would be how you would
build that right that P map can take
it'll put the whole results of that
function fun to hear
it'll pass it those variables and then
[Applause]
and we have more stuff coming up
throughout the year so thank you very
much another end of the plaza Judy talk
to me will know more about the next
beautiful workshop for the bar
thank you so much I've already know
little I needed to hear I want to see
how you could write up SQL code
literally output yeah